Nanami is the dad, that Itadori never had.
I think, out of all the complex and tragic
characters we have met in Jujutsu Kaisen so
far, Nanami Kento is without any doubt the
most complete character.
He has stuff figured out.
Listening to Nanami is like listening to your
parents or friends, when you don't want to
admit they have a point, but they really do.
And so interestingly enough, in a world full
of eccentric, powerful and badass characters,
of all things it's the guy who's most defining
trait is being the normal grown up in the
room, that is so relatable and, quite rightfully,
enjoys popularity that rivals that of Gojo.
How can that be?
Now, I'm gonna say right of the bat that of
course, despite his mannerism and appearance,
there is very little normal about Nanami in
general.
I mean the guy runs around with a blunt blade
covered in anti-curse charms to basically
butcher his way through enemies.
But as you will see, it's exactly this contrast
between the two worlds, the regular one and
the jujutsu one, that make him such a relatable
and intriguing person.
This 'act' he'a putting on, of being just
a regular tie-wearing office guy in a sightly
unusual line of work, is a central part of
his identity and moral perspective.
So, why did he run away form the Jujutsu world?
How did he get so powerful?
And what makes him one of the most influential
people for Itadori and the story overall?
This is the story of Nanami Kento.
First things first, a quick direction of Nanami's
abilities as a Jujutsu-Shi.
While Nanami's anime is written with the Kanji
for 7 and sea, his name can also be read as
nana-mi as in 7 and 3, making it a bit of
a pun with his innate 7:3 ratio powers, that
allows him to divide a target of his choice
with ten lines and forcibly creates weak spots
at the ratio point of seven to three.
While this ability, is without any doubt powerful,
it requires excellent motor coordination,
that Nanami demonstrates together with fantastic
athleticism and strength.
While not able to form his own domain, as
a Grade 1 sorcerer, he can use black flash,
a powerful application of concentrated cursed
energy.
Most interestingly however, Nanami has created
a binding vow with himself, called overtime,
that limits the amount of cursed energy he
can utilize during the time he's officially
on the clock working for Jujutsu High.
Once he goes beyond his normal shift however,
and overtime hours begin, Nanami's cursed
energy swells to a great degree, granting
him a significant boost in fighting power.
-
While Nanami might not appear to be the most
creative or complex on the surface, you only
need to go a little bit deeper to find that
in Akutami's net of carefully crafted characters,
he is one of the most multi-layered and thought-through
personalities in the story.
This becomes especially clear when we look
at the two main functions of his in the story:
Being a father figure to Itadori and drawing
you dear viewer, deeper into the story.
Let's start with the latter.
To understand, how what makes Nanami so important
in terms of world building, I want to give
you a quick overview of the world in Jujutsu
Kaisen.
Much more so than many other anime, JuJutsu
Kaisen has taken it as a central designing
principle to integrate this supernatural world
of courses and sorcerers into a real and timely
depiction of our world.
As someone living in Tokyo myself, I can attest
to 100% that Akutami has literally taken the
real modern Japan and integrated his own world
as a hidden hub within it.
This in itself is nothing new, it's something
we for example also see in Bleach, one of
the major inspirations for the story.
However, whole Ichigo and co keep jumping
form one world to the next and there rarely
seem to be references to the real world, in
Jujutsu Kaisen, both sorcerers and Curses
alike are part of modern life.
As a result, we see Nobora shopping in Shibuya,
Tojo going to Idol meet-ups, Gojo making Itadori
watch hours of famous Hollywood movies, Geto
and the curses meeting up in a family restaurant
and even principal gakuganji, who first is
introduced as the typical old-guy-preserving-traditions-and-following-the-rules-at-any-cost
type of character, turns out to have powers
that have him use an electric guitar.
The most eye-catching thing however, might
be the use of smart-phones in the story.
As the Nerdwriter, one of my favorite YouTubers,
fantastically explains in one of his videos,
the reason, we usually get so few smartphones
in Movies and Shows, is the addictive, time-consuming
and never stopping data mining we constantly
perform on our smartphones.
Many of us have started to resent the way
these devices control our lives and nourish
our insecurities
and fears.
- Nerdwriter - JuJutsu Kaisen on the other
hand is all about confronting fears and insecurities
and figuring out what is worth giving our
time and even our lives for.
And I think no other character represents
this better than Nanami.
He is depicted in a full suit and tie, with
neat haircut - nothing less than salaryman
image Gojo calls him.
Without his unique glasses, you won’t be
able to differentiate him from common office
worker.
He’s the stiff seriousness formality in
contrast to Gojo’s easy, overly friendly
and overly informal attitude.
Even during their first meeting, he demands
a formal introduction from Itadori.
He's the type of guy that likes following
rules and procedures.
Nanami's image as the normal guy, who used
to work both as a salary man and a Sorcerer,
helps us connect to the world of Jujutsu Kaisen,
better than maybe any other character.
For him, office work is shit -- but so is
being a Jujutsu sorcerer.
We all can relate that working over-hours
in a boring office job, is not merely boring
and dissatisfying, it's draining.
And Nanami basically putting this type of
work and jujutsu on the same level, makes
the actions of gojo, itadori and co suddenly
a lot more relatable and real as well.
Yes, being able to do a domain expansion might
be dope, but in the end being a jujutsu sorcerer
is just as shit a job as working yourself
to death as a salary man.
-- Just like smartphones, we usually don't
like seeing the unpleasantness of a boring
and draining job reflected back at us when
watching something.
And yet JuJutsu Kaisen, uses these elements
consciously to create a realistic vibe, while
at the same time enforcing the central moral
question of the story: What does it mean to
live a good life, worth living.
Nanami is the first character in this series
of character analysis, that has a flat character
arc, in other words, he knows the truth about
the world, that most other characters have
to figure out.
Nanami knows that in general, the world is
mostly shit.
Jujutsu sucks, doing a normal job sucks.
In other words, life itself doesn't present
you with a deeper purpose and happiness by
itself.
Nanami came to this realization after initially
running away from the terrors associated with
being a sorcerer.
Seeing his comrades die and suffer around
him, had a deep impact on Nanami, who, as
we will discuss in a bit, despite his hard
shell has an incredibly soft core.
So, he decided to run away, work his ass of
as a salary man and earn enough so he could
retire early somewhere outside of Japan, away
from the Jujutsu world and all the suffering.
And yet, the office work drained him just
as much and made him maybe even more unhappy.
Pointlessly thinking about money the entire
day, while failing to live his life in the
moment.
And so, while it might seem like a minor thing
in the context of the story, the two scenes
of Nanami visiting the bread store are actually
the most defining of his entire character.
Because as he decides to release the girl
from the burden of the curse on her shoulder
after all, that neither she nor any doctor
can see, Nanami finally realizes, that while
life is shit and offers no purpose in itself,
he himself is free to find his own purpose
and fulfillment in life.
And while Itadori has only inherited his wish
to help others from his grandpa, and hasn't
really figure out himself why that matters,
Nanami in this moment understands, that helping
others is what gives his live meaning.
While being a Jujutsu-shi might be just as
bad or, considering all the violence and death,
worse a job than working in an office job,
as a sorcerer he has the rare ability to help
others who are suffering under the terror
of curses.
And this conclusion is very important.
Because someone like Mshito for example also
understands this truth about the world.
However, as a result to this insight, he decides
to simply live out his desire to fight and
hurt others.
As always with flat characters, the most important
thing is how the use their knowledge to influence
the world, either for the good or bad.
Now the second major role Nanami plays in
the story is that of the adult in the room
and ultimately one of the most influential
people on Itadoris development.
This becomes especially clear when looking
at his relationships with Yuji, Gojo and even
Mahito.
All three of them are immature in different
ways.
Itadori of course literally is a kid, that
has grown up without his parents and as so
many shounen heroes has been thrown into a
world of violence.
Mahito is a newly born curse, that like a
child likes to play around and try things
out, such as testing his own powers or having
out with a human to see what it's like.
Finally, Gojo himself, who is actually Nanami's
senior, can be quite serious and frightening
at times, but as I discuss in depth in his
video, is nonetheless emotionally immature.
And while ironically, all three of them turn
out to be stronger than Nanami, in their interactions
with him, their immaturity becomes clear.
Nanami is in many ways an alternative version
of Gojo.
While the strongest sorcerer is charismatic,
eccentric and un-conformist, Nanami represents
a sorcerer who follows the rules, sees the
work they do as a job and is fairly reasonable
and straight laced in his behavior.
He seems to believe in a higher, external
set of rules and values, that everyone should
conform to.
Goodness and righteousness in particular are
two ideals that define his life, and that
end up shaping him, even if he tries to avoid
then.
In that sense, Nanami is different from Yuji
or Fushiguro, he doesn't actually want to
save everyone or even the ones he holds dear,
knowing fully well it's not possible for him.
And yet whenever he's faced with the option
to help, he does so, holding himself to his
own high standards.
All despite not being a very self righteous
person himself.
Gojo has a high opinion of himself, but low
social skills, and low compliance with others.
Nanami is his inversion, he has a low opinion
of himself, but he’s geared much more to
watching over and cooperating with others.
This results in the disrespect he has for
Gojo and his methods of handling things, but
goes out of his way to cooperate with him
and not let his personal opinions interfere
with his work.
And this difference is reflected perfectly
in their approach to teaching.
While Gojo is great at bringing Yuji up to
speed in terms of power, basically crash-coursing
him into being a first class sorcerer in mere
weeks, due to his own character flaw, he can't
teach Itadori on an emotional and human level.
This is where Nanami comes in.
While he doesn't make Yuji any stronger, he
teaches him about morality, duty and in general
what it means being a part of the Jujutsu
world.
He also, allows Yuji, who reminds him of his
own time as student, to be a kid, which, even
though it might annoy him at first, is incredibly
important for dealing with the flaws and struggles
that come with being a teenager that suddenly
has to make complex moral decisions, like
taking a human life and that is way to reckless
with his own life already.
Instead of throwing Itadori into the fire,
like Gojo does, he gives Itadori the option
to say no.
Nanami is a sort of parental figure for Itadori,
that, while strict, gives him a sense of security
and guidance.
And most importantly, he gives Yuji a feeling
of achievement and attention by believing
in him and his abilities.
In the world of Jujutsu the kids have to risk
their lives while the higher ups pull their
strings behind the scenes, safely away from
the action, not caring about their suffering
and pain.
that’s why nanami keeps saying things like
“being a child is not a sin” and “it’s
my duty to prioritize your life over mine”
because he's trying to do what the higher-ups
should have been doing all along, which is
trying to keep these kids Safe and let them
grow into responsible adults.
This care for the students and the dislike
of the established structures is one of the
few things he actually has in common with
Gojo.
Nanami is an oddity among the sorcery world
not for being an eccentric but for being too
normal.
He’s too much of a functioning adult.
He’s not insane enough like most sorcerers,
which is the case for a goo reason.
- Gojo explains not everyone can do it - That’s
because Nanami’s number one priority is
not strength, but rather connecting and cooperating
with others hence why he’s so strong on
conformism.
And so, in the end, Nanami’s salaryman-like
serious persona becomes more and more of an
act as you dwell on his character.
It’s like he’s putting on a show that
he’s not as mad as everybody else, that
he’s still reasonable in this world.
It’s done mostly for his own sake because
Nanami is striving to follow his own ideals
of being good, in a world he’s well aware
is not so good.
While being an incredibly sensitive and loving
person at heart, he always forces himself
to be strict because he believes he has to.
The moment that best shows this, is during
his fight with Mahito, where he is quite empathic
to the transfigured humans used by Mahito
in their fight, despite claiming that he doesn’t
bring his personal feeling to work.
And it's this fatherly nature of his, the
feeling that there is an adult in the room
who knows what has to be done, that make Nanami
such a well-respected and dearly loved character.
And while, despite his best efforts, Nanami
is simply not blessed with the powers of a
Gojo or Itadori, he is able to pass on his
will and drive to the next generation.
While he might feel like just another clog
in the system, just like the accumulation
of little despairs made him grow up, the accumulation
of little acts of kindness are what create
an impact in the grand scale of things, making
his life worth living.
Which is why in the face of death, Nanami
is actually able to smile, having lived his
life suffering, but without regret.
Now, while Nanami in many ways is a more mature
version of Itadori, having passed his philosophy
onto him, the student that is actually most
like Gojo, is not Fushiguro, but actually
Kugisaki Nobora, a refreshingly badass take
on the female support character in shounen.
-
Make sure to watch her video by clicking right
here.
Thanks for watching.
Peace.